hi I'm Jake Solomon creative director on
XCOM 2
XCOM 2 is being developed by Firaxis
games and just like its predecessor
XCOM enemy unknown XCOM 2 is a
turn-based strategy game but an X come
to the tables have been turned and earth
is now under alien rule
ants have established a new world order
and XCOM has gone underground as a
resistance movement in this point of the
game it's the 20th anniversary of
unification day which is the day that
Earth's surrendered to the aliens and
you're going to see that Advent have
built this beautiful big sculpture in
the heart of the city center and that is
going to be X coms target you're going
to watch XCOM soldiers go on a sabotage
mission which is one of the new mission
types you're going to experience an X
come to so we hope you enjoy and thank
you for watching preparations are
already underway in cities across the
globe today marking the 20 year
anniversary a unification day the very
beginnings of the Advent coalition
celebration thousands flock to the site
of the great Accord hard to forget the
impassioned message of last year's
commencement address Earth's corrupt
political body struck first against a
peaceful visitor resulting in
devastation that left hundreds of
millions with nothing if not for the
enduring patience an in generosity of
the elders for recent arrests of the
radicals behind the assault of the gene
therapy center
Advent has assured all citizens that
today's celebration will continue as
planned I've heard enough signal gate
pressure take it down
all right gate crasher Advent little
circus is dead ahead keep a low profile
and deliver the package remember the
crowd as I'm distracted take advantage
we engage on our terms they won't know
what it is Roger that
it's bigger TV better get your last
looks now pressure to advance
on my way
security is tight they're not as
confident as they seem on it
double-time
crashing for Europe encourage all
citizens with information on this
troubled individual to come for the
future we're working on it advance
understood much
admins got this whole city in their crib
we're going to have to go through why
just we'll get the drop on that first
you got it
eyes open
holding position
coppy
you've got the green light make it count
going loud target down
five
I think we just got their attention
crasher to deliver the package
coppy approaching target
closing one position
here they come and it be true a pro
yeah that was close
one take that thing out
ah
and stays out
already there
yeah
that's how it's done
the window is glitter crasher to deliver
the package going in
stay focused soldier deliver the package
and get out of there
you tell me twice
Chloe one position we just picked up a
transmission and coming
Oh erm
or kotuku it down
I can't deliver let's clean up the rest
of this mess
do your thing baby
attempting infiltrators
got it
going hot
Oh
clear well done Gatecrasher we just put
Advent on notice
rendezvous it hell it got you can't take
that thing head-on fall back now
blaka
crash or three response
she got cold on the move
let's get you out of here
I want you both better there by a
brother's position Bret free backing
down
we bacon
you